over the years magic I like knew you
were in some interview were talking
about how you knew that friends would be
a big hit like quite early on there was
there in a specific episode Jinyu I did
know that friends was gonna be ahead I
didn't know that it was gonna be the
giant hit that it was I tell you today
but there was one episode where there
was a blackout in New York City and I
was stuck in an ATM vestibule with Jill
Goodacre that was that we in it she was
in it yes you'd know that if you'd lost
it
yes I was stuck in an ATM vestibule with
her so she was in it friends yeah the TV
show press yeah and that show that
episode really made me think that we
were doing something special because I
supposed you were kind of a way for you
could see the others in the apply could
see the others in the apartment and the
audience was really laughing and it just
felt like the right thing and there was
a spooky thing that when you got the
scripts of where you auditioned I mean
you it wasn't that you kind of thought I
could be that guy yeah well I was
unavailable because I had done this
terrible TV show about baggage handlers
in the year 2199 friends were all
auditioning for the show called friends
and there was this character named
Chandler who was very similar to me so I
would help them with their auditions and
I finally said let me just do this for
you just imitate what I'm doing and go
in and some of them got very far and
almost got the job and then somebody
finally saw the baggage handlers show
and decided that wasn't gonna get picked
up and then they allowed me to be on
friends Wow
well is it our office I think has more
than its fair share of friends geeks
okay like you know the famous quiz
episode when the girls lose the
apartment yes I remember that okay yeah
so what the guys wanted you to see if
you could remember the answers to the
Chandler questions in the quiz if you
can't Gemma artisans write on it
do you remember this episode no Miriam
no hope
so if only don't shut out till Matthew
don't get it but feel free to shout out
if you can then get it okay sure is on
okay here we go here we go according to
Chandler what phenomenon scares the
bejesus out of them
oh that's Michael Flatley lord of the
Damned you are correct yes okay what is
the name of Chandler's father's all-male
burlesque
I actually know that - that's Viva Las
Vegas you'll definitely know this one
you will definitely know this one every
week the TV Guide comes to Chandler and
Joey's apartment what name appears on
the address label
mrs. Chandler bong the last one the last
one is what because this is the famous
thing that no one although Chandler was
the only one with a kind of a proper job
right throughout the series it was never
kind of talked about what he actually
danced right it was in computers
something computers so should we see of
anyone the audience knows this before do
you do you know where I am I'm not sure
so does anyone know what is Chandler's
job oh there's a hand a hand back up
there see wait wait there's got to be a
microphone coming to you one second what
do you think job was transponster gone -
Rachel no know anyone else or a guest
oh no there's a lady the back lady the
back oh you're having to get a very
strange angle we we've never spoken to
anyone the back row before Hey yes
statistical data reconfiguration oh
you're so close you're so close that's
what it actually is statistical analysis
and data reconfiguration she's so close
and the guy at my channel on came back
from the bathroom and my friend said
that's not my Mariana life what is the
name of Chandler's father's all-male
burlesque
I actually know that - that's Viva Las
Vegas